uh William Barr was Donald Trump's
Attorney General
and William Barr I do not consider a
friend of the Progressive Movement
William Barr is not someone I would even
remotely consider for attorney general
but William Barr does have some legal
expertise there is no question about
that and William Barr went on Fox News
Sunday and said that if half of the new
Federal indictment Federal indictment
against Trump is true
Trump is toast this is super interesting
stuff it wildly triggered Donald Trump
let's listen to what Barr had to say and
he's making a lot of sense here
um what about this this Chief argument
that comes up for the president's allies
and his legal team that this should have
been handled under the presidential
records act not this espion act
Espionage Act charge in other Federal
statutes that were used here well it
started out under the presidential
records act and and the archives trying
to retrieve documents that Trump had no
right to have but it quickly became
clear that what the government was
really worried about were these
classified and very sensitive documents
I was shocked by the degree of
sensitivity of these documents and how
many there were frankly
and uh so the government's agenda was to
get those uh protect those documents and
get them out and I think it was
perfectly appropriate to do that it was
the right thing to do and I think the
counts under the Espionage Act that he
willfully retained those documents or
solid counts now I I do think we have to
wait and see what the defense says and
and what proves to be true but I do
think that even half what Andy McCarthy
said which is if even half of it is true
then he's toast I mean it's a it's a
pretty it's a very detailed indictment
and it's very very damning okay that is
an extraordinary statement and it also
sort of deals with one of the claims
that so-called legal experts like Mark
Levin are making which is that this
stuff isn't even really related to the
criminal world of law that this is all
just presidential records act subject to
that and William Barr says sure
initially it was subject to that but
between based on the evidence in the
indictment which includes alleged
obstruction and it includes all of these
other things that Trump is accused of
doing it becomes criminal and that's
that's it it's short you can say until
you're you're blue in the face this is
presidential record stuff it went
criminal when Trump covered it up tried
to keep the documents potentially tried
to destroy documents etc etc uh and that
is absolutely very very serious stuff
then we go to Fox news's favorite legal
commentator Jonathan Turley Jonathan
Turley has been defending Trump
reflexively for year years now on so
many different issues even Jonathan
Turley says this is a very damning
indictment listen to this president
gozad to say well what if we what
happens if we just don't respond at all
to The subpoena I guess or don't play
ball with them the president goes on to
say wouldn't it be better if we just
told them we don't have anything here
well look isn't it better if there are
no documents uh you know they they've
got these conversations that were
memorialized by the president's
attorneys there's also this recording of
him where he talks about this plan
that's believed an attack plan against
Iran I mean they've got a lot of
information in this Jonathan
no it is an extremely damning indictment
uh you know there are indictments there
are sometimes called narrative or
speaking indictments these are
indictments uh that are really meant to
uh make a point as to the depth of the
evidence there are some indictments that
are just Bare Bones this is not uh the
special counsel uh knew that there would
be a lot of people who were going to
allege uh that the Department of Justice
was acting in a biased or politically
motivated way this is clearly an
indictment uh that was drafted to answer
those questions it's overwhelming and
detailed and you know the Trump team
should not fool itself these are hits
below the water line uh these are
witnesses who apparently testified under
oath gave statements to Federal
investigators both of which can be
criminally charged if they're false
those Witnesses are directly quoting the
president uh in in encouraging others
not to look for documents or allegedly
to conceal them it's damaging and the
key here to keep in mind is that every
case I've ever been involved with the
indictment was a Heart Stopper you know
these are written by lawyers who are
trying to convict a client every
indictment I've ever dealt with has
fallen apart to some degree once we look
more carefully about the evidence may be
but this is is not a an indictment that
you can dismiss all right so there is
Jonathan Turley even with his hemming
and hawing saying this is very serious
stuff back to William Barr William Barr
putting the blame for all of this
squarely on Trump and that's where it
should be so and we can't forget here
that this entire thing came about
because of Reckless conduct
of the president if he had just turned
over the documents which I think every
other person in the country would have
done the government's documents their
official records they're not his
personal records battle plans for an
attack on another country or or defense
department documents about our
capabilities are in no universe Donald J
Trump's personal documents and then
lastly from William Barr
Trump's claims that other presidents did
the same thing Barr debunks it good for
him to his credit he is undoing every
single one of these Trump arguments this
took all these documents those were
situations where they arranged with the
archives to set up special space under
the management control and security
provided by the archivist to temporarily
put documents until the libraries were
ready because we're not people just
putting them in their basement okay and
the second thing that the president this
idea that that that the president has
complete authority to declare any
document personal is obvious it's
facially ridiculous that opinion had to
do with the distinction between official
records which are records prepared by
government agencies for the purpose of
government action
and personal documents as opposed to
official documents which are things
prepared by the president such as a
diary or notes which are not used in the
government's deliberations and yes as to
the second class stuff that the
president himself generates the
president has some discretion but these
are official documents it's an arguable
yep listen
um William Barr you don't have to like
them to recognize that he is on much
stronger legal footing here than a
random Fox news commentator indignantly
saying there's nothing here William Barr
is right and that's why it so triggered
Donald Trump when he said this let's
talk about that briefly next people
often ask me about my daily routine you
know I'm interviewed about the David
Pacman show how did you do it how do you
do this and like daily routine just
often comes up and how do you stay
healthy and of course I talk about
exercise and I talk about eating the
right diet but one of the things that
can happen if you are not eating the
right diet diet or you're traveling or
life gets in the way is you end up with
some kind of vitamin deficiency a daily
scoop of ag-1 from our sponsor athletic
greens makes this super easy to take off
of your list of things to worry about
one scoop of ag1 you get the entire
day's worth of 75 high quality vitamins
and minerals from Whole Food sourced
ingredients ag-1 is cheaper than dealing
with a bunch of different supplements
it's infinitely more convenient you just
take a scoop before you have your coffee
for example as I do in the morning and
you're covered for the entire day many
of my friends love ag1 anyone I mention
it to seems to get hooked when I go on
vacation I bring the ag1 travel packs
with me especially because I'm not
always eating the same diet when I'm
traveling that I do at home staying
properly nourished so important to
feeling your best ag1 just makes it
really easy and very convenient go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman to get a free
year supply of vitamin D I've talked
about vitamin D so many times plus five
free ag1 travel packs the link is down
below